عالم التقنيه العالم الذين نعيش فيه
ويمتلك كل ما نملك ان صح التعبير بكل
بساطه اذا كنت تستخدم هاتفك في تصفح مواقع
التواصل او في تعاملات شرائيه وبنكيه فانت
بذلك فتحت باب تسريب بياناتك الشخصيه بناء
على تحولات التي حصلت خلال العام الجاري
في عالم الانترنت يتوقع خبراء التقنيه ان
يشهد عام 20 23 تغيرات في مجال الشراء
الالكتروني او حتى الخصوصيه لهذا حذرت
مؤسسات حكوميه وخاصه من اتساع عمليات
الاحتيال وقدمت عده نصائح لتجنبها ابرز ان
نصائح تتمحور حول التحذير من زياده
الرسائل البنكيه المزيفه التي تصل لك عبر
الهاتف المحمول وتحمل اغراءات بالكسب
السريعه شركه كسبريس كل المتخصصه في الامن
السيبراني وضع تصورا لعالم الرقمنا من
ابرز ملامحيه ان الهواتف الذكيه سيكون لها
مكان اكبر في تعاملاتنا وسيصبح نموذج
جزء من الواقع
[موسيقى]